- Split up, you go over
here, you go over here.
I'm gonna be a great dad.
What's your name?
Star and Stella, just get
up on in here, there we go.
Yes!
Thing I miss most about being
in a band with my brothers
is just the traveling aspect of it.
You know, they were with
me every step of the way,
we got to see amazing
places in the world together
and it was a beautiful time in our lives.
Come back to me.
Knowing that people are
having sex to my music
is the best thing in the world.
I just require a commission by way
of naming the child after me.
Nicholas, Nick, Nikki, Nicolette,
this should be the exchange.
- What inspired me to write it?
This little guy obviously.
What inspired me to write it was that...
Oh yeah!
This is so fun.
I can't focus when this is happening,
so I was at Coachella actually.
Hey!
Play nice.
Was in a tent and...
Thank you.
Get in there.
And basically, it was
very inspiring and...
Favorite song I ever written
in my career is Jealous.
Really important song for
me when I broke off solo.
It just captioned a moment of time for me.
What do you think?
What's your favorite song in your career?
Growing up in a house full of guys,
my mom's a very strong woman,
she had a lot of boys around all the time.
Come here, I need your cuteness!
We were a handful.
Imagine when we all left the nest,
that's what it felt like for her.
They gotta be honest,
trustworthy and a dog person,
not a cat person, kidding,
they can have a cat, it's fine
just, prefer dogs.
There's one right in front
of you, there you go.
My best piece of dating advice is,
be upfront, be honest, even if at times,
it's not always exactly what you think
the person wants to hear, always,
the truth is better than being dishonest
or not being upfront, right?
Right.
There's a little bit
of healthy competition
between my brother and
I, but I am the godfather
of one of my nieces.
I did wear a pinstripe
suit to her dedication so,
I'm fully the godfather.
The best part about is,
you get to play with them
and hang out with them but then,
you get a full night's sleep.
Ultimate cheat meal, pizza, every time
or a cheeseburger or a bacon cheeseburger.
A burger pizza.
Smash them together.
Alright.
Can you get out, you can't get out.
I do watch Game of Thrones, I
have many favorite characters
but every time I like a
character, they get killed.
So I have to now, if I like a character,
not say who I like because,
they just die right away.
Joe has never given me
a wedgie, that's a lie.
Straight lie, straight from his mouth.
He's full of shit, you tell him I said so.
Do it, rip the set out,
just eat it, eat them all.
Lots of memorable moments
from my Disney days,
we used to do Disney Channel Games
which was a good time, they would collect
all of us from the different shows
and then put us together at Disney World.
Really, it was like summer camp.
We had the park to ourselves some nights
and lots of drama because we
were all dating each other.
It's like high school.
Amazing!
♫ Happy birthday to you
- Thank you so much.
- Guys, that was beautiful, thank you.
I'm not allowed to eat this shit.
Mm-hmm.